hu a dit salem 41 ans est en train de
quitter le ch et celle des de montréal
où ils habitent dans les derniers jours
le nombre de cas de kobe 19,6 multiplier
dans l'établissement apeuré il a demandé
de partir le plus rapidement possible
j'ai adoré mon ami j'ai dit je veux
sortir de nouveau crevé et des mois
certains il a été placé temporairement
dans une autre résidence ils se portent
bien mais ne veut plus retourner en ch
et celle des mais ce n'est pas au milieu
de vie c'est françois marcotte 47 ans
atteint de sclérose en plaques a fait
une sortie publique qui a défrayé les
manchettes en 2016 je prédis de l'emploi
il avait lancé un cri du coeur pour
obtenir trois douches par semaine dans
son centre d'hébergement
il vit toujours au ch et celle des dans
la région québec en attendent un
résultat de test de la côte et disney
channel est là mais ses résidents plus
jeunes se retrouvent souvent au ch et
c'est le départ manque d'options
ils savent bien qu'ils n'y sont pas à
leur place surtout ces jours-ci
d'ailleurs jonathan marchand qui
souffrent de dystrophie musculaire se
bat depuis quelques années afin qu'ils
puissent bénéficier d'une assistance
personnalisée à domicile sur ce que j'ai
besoin c'est le financement d'une partie
de l'argent que leur cote pour manière
détruits pour que je te sortir un mode
de vie que le gériatre et ancien député
réjean hébert prioriserait également il
ya eu dans les années 80 tout un
mouvement de désinstitutionnalisation et
malheureuse bas c'est cette
désinstitutionnalisation europe a été
pérennisée le gouvernement compte revoir
tout le réseau des ch et celle des
élancées plutôt prévu le chantier des
maisons des aînés la réflexion devrait
aussi porter sur le sort de ces jeunes
résidant ici mélissa françois radio
canada montréal